ich habe am sonntag völlig zufällig den
autokorso einen langen großen autokorso
mit russischen flaggen hier mitten in
berlin gesehen
dutzende von autos
hupend fuhren durch die stadt ich habe
erst mal überhaupt nicht verstanden
worum es geht dann gab es ein paar
schilder an den autos mann soll die
russen nicht hassen dieser autokorso
wirkt sie auf mich beängstigend ich
komme selbst aus russland muss ich dazu
sagen erinnerte mich auch an die langen
reihen von russischen militärfahrzeugen
in der ukraine von seiner ganzen
aufmachung mit dem aggressiven hupen und
ich dachte mir oh gott oh gott wie wird
das wohl ankommen wenn das hier erst mal
gesehen sind der nächste gedanke war
bestimmt wurde dass die von russischen
botschaft organisiert denn niemand wird
doch wirklich an einem tag an dem wir
die kriegsverbrechen den user sehen
einen solchen autokorso organisieren
ohne sich zu überlegen wie das ankommt
dann habe ich mich damit beschäftigt wer
das war und es hat sich herausgestellt
es ist ein auto werkstatt unternehmer
der das ganze auf die beine stellte ich
bin ihnen die geschlossene gruppe von
diesen telegramm gruppe von diesem auto
kursen reingegangen und habe
recherchiert was für menschen sind da
was treibt sie an glauben sie wirklich
daran dass der krieg in der ukraine eine
gute sache ist wollten die uns etwa das
hier zeigen ich habe dort eine umfrage
gemacht und in dieser umfrage dies auf
russisch durchgeführt habe ich eben
gefragt unterstützt hier den krieg oder
unterstützt ihn nicht ich habe sogar
gefragt unterstützt diese
spezialoperation um niemanden in eine
ecke zu drängen nur 18 prozent haben
sich als unterstützer dieses krieges
geoutet 70 prozent haben gesagt ich bin
gegen diesen krieg das ist eine
aggression russlands ein überraschendes
ergebnis für mich und auch ein ganz
wichtiges ergebnis die mehrheit der
russen in deutschland und auch selbst
bei diesem auto korso unterstützt nicht
diesen krieg und wer die russen als
unterstützer von diesem krieg dich hier
mit uns in unserem land leben hin stellt
der spiel den ball in die hände viele
die ich hier dabei waren haben gar nicht
verstanden wo sie damit machen und wie
das wirkt und deshalb appelliere ich nur
dafür nicht alle russen in deutschland
als unterstützer von diesem krieg ab zu
ich hätte hier eine frage die erste
frage ist es heißt ja immer so schön
nicht wissen halt schützt nicht
dementsprechend wenn man das natürlich
mitgemacht hat und mitgetragen hat dann
kann man jetzt nicht sagen man ist froh
ukraine und die zweite frage die ich
habe wenn das stimmt und ich hoffe sehr
dass es stimmt dass die mehrheit der
russen für die befreiung der ukraine
sind und dass sie also dafür sind dass
putin weggehauen wird und dass der
aggressor zurück weichen muss warum sehe
ich dann keine präklinischen aufmärsche
von russen in deutschland warum gibt es
diese demonstration nicht warum zeigt
man es nicht nach außen wir stehen
hinter der ukraine
die frage muss man glaube ich denn die
kollegen von den medien richten gerade
am freitag war hier in berlin eine
demonstration die von bussen organisiert
vor der russischen botschaft von
organisationen westen heißt frühling
stattgefunden hat davon habe ich nichts
gesehen ich habe jetzt diesen autokorso
auf seite eins vieler zeitungen gesehen
auch dieser bilder richtig also auch an
die medienleute auch diejenigen mal
sichtbar zu machen auch mal an dem
berliner hauptbahnhof zu gehen und die
helfer die dort ein russisches also als
russisch sprach ich eindeutig
ausgewiesen sind mal zu fragen wo kommst
du eigentlich her und ganz viele werden
sagen ich komme aus russland oder ich
komme als pilger aus belarus einem
freund von mir hat mir heute erzählt
eine gute freundin von ihm kommt aus
belarus ein flüchtling hat sie gefragt
wo sie herkommt sie sagte aus belarus
daraufhin hat er sie angespuckt sie ist
er als helferin im einsatz aber das ist
auch bei jemanden der als kriegsopfer
nach deutschland kommt den krieg in
fluren das nachvollziehbar bloß wir
sollten den fehler nicht machen schauen
wir uns doch mal wirklich an wie viele
russen russlanddeutsche und andere
abends an diesen bahnhöfen stehen
lebensmittel verteilen
hilfstransport organisieren
hilfstransporte fahren tage lang ohne
schlaf ganz ganz viele davon sind russen
es fliegen ja auch viele menschen aus
russland also sozusagen vor denen immer
weniger demokratisch und rechtsstaatlich
werden den verhältnissen und dem und dem
staatsterror dort also auch die werden
natürlich hier in der gesellschaft dann
irgendwie aufgenommen und den dürften
auf gar keinen fall
mithaftung genommen werden und natürlich
gibt es immer eine gefahr dass man in
einer ohnehin komplexen situation auf
einfache feindbilder reduziert trotzdem
würde mich mal interessieren was haben
sie denn ist denn in dieser telegramm
gruppe danach mal diskutiert worden wie
das gewirkt hat und ob das so eine
glückliche idee war oder dass leute
gesagt haben das hätten wir vielleicht
lieber bleiben lassen also ich nehme
auch den vorwurf an die medien sofort an
ich weiß es schlicht nicht also ob wir
genug gucken wo russen sich jetzt soll
die sozusagen solidarisieren mit den
ukrainern das nehme ich jetzt einfach
mal mit aber diese sache hat ja nun
stattgefunden und der zeitpunkt war
denkbar ungünstig und die wirkung leider
auch also ist da ist gab es danach
klappt dann die selbstkritik hält sich
noch in grenzen die wortführer dort sind
kriegsbefürworter ohne ist groß da hatte
ich eine große glocke zu hängen und sich
dazu zu bekennen ist ganz klar hinter
putin nicht die nummer eins der hält
sich zurück aber so ein bisschen die
führungsgruppe dahinter sind wirklich
ganz viele hinter putin und diese 18
prozent die für diese spezialoperation
sich bekannt haben sind sehr lautstark
ich glaube dass nachdenken von fängt
jetzt erst dann es gibt eine gegen
gruppe von ukrainern organisiert bei
telegramm wo jedes einzelne auto
abfotografiert mit kennzeichen mit einem
aufruf das auto zu beschädigen die
person anzugreifen eingestellt wurde
erst jetzt wird langsam verstanden
welches ausmaß man eigentlich an
abneigung erreicht hat mit einer
demonstration deren ziel war
diskriminierung zu vermeiden genau das
hat man jetzt geschafft genau das
gegenteil von dem was man eigentlich
wirklich nicht sichtbar und ich glaube
ich meine es war 900 personen die sich
dort getroffen haben 400 autos ich weiß
dass die demonstration ist sie
angesprochen haben die russische die die
solidarität mit der ukraine gezeigt
vielleicht können sie dann nochmal ein
ordner wie viele das waren dass wir da
auch darüber berichten das möchte ich
nicht auf mir sitzen lassen aber für das
verständnis pochen das was natürlich
auch ab einer gewissen größe dann auch
der fall ist das war da besonders
auffällig dass 900 menschen mitgemacht
und ich glaube man kann sich nicht davor
verstecken dass man nicht wusste was
dort passiert selbst wenn man sagt man
möchte gegen oder für mehr verständnis
oder man möchte auch davor warnen dass
kein hass geschürt wird jetzt zwischen
uns ein ich glaube ich muss man sich
schon fragen ob das ein guter zeitpunkt
ist mit großen russischen fahnen jetzt
quer durch berlin hupend am hauptbahnhof
vorbei zu fahren an einem tag wo einst
grauen grauenvolle bilder aus butter
allen die das schlecht ich finde diese
verantwortung kann sich kein mensch der
dort mitgefahren ist ziehen
kann ich leider auch so nicht gelten
lassen das war der schlechteste
zeitpunkt dennoch blieb das erklärte
ziel dieser demonstration und der die
offizielle anmeldung eben eine
demonstration gegen diskriminierung und
wenn man das erreichen wollte hat man
genau das gegenteil erreicht deshalb
kann ich wirklich auch an eigentlich
muslim russland sondern kontaminierung
russland oder war das eine demonstration
gegen diskriminierung deutschland einmal
eindruck ist eigentlich dass wir es in
russland mit einem land zu tun haben das
extrem hart diskriminiert seine eigene
bevölkerung
das thema diskriminierung ist meiner
erkenntnis nach in deutschland
eigentlich
immer
mir ist nicht bekannt dass
auch jemand der ein russe ist und hier
eine russische flagge hoch hält
beispielsweise ins gefängnis kommt das
passiert das land alle tage also auch da
glaube ich ist es bemerkenswert dass
sich russen in deutschland auf die
straße stellen und sagen wir kämpfen
hier gegen diskriminierung
mein eindruck ist dass es in ihrem
eigenen heimatland der fall david
schwerst diskriminiert da wird gefoltert
aber das passiert nicht